atterrissage en alaska anthony blinken
se prépare un premier face à face avec
son homologue chinois wang dit dans un
climat de guerre froide
le chef de la diplomatie américaine
entend bien ouvrir des dossiers brûlants
pendant ces deux jours de pourparlers
nous allons discuter de nos profondes
inquiétudes au sujet des actes de la
chine
s'agissant du xingjiang de hong kong de
taïwan
des cyber attaques contre les états unis
et de la coercition économie contre nos
alliés chacun de ces actes menace un
ordre fondé sur des règles qui
garantissent la stabilité mondiale c'est
pourquoi il ne s'agit pas seulement de
questions intérieures et nous ressentons
l'obligation d'en parler ici aujourd'hui
blinken ne prend pas de gants la chine
elle temporise à notre niveau je pense
qu'ils dévient tels que nous fassions
tout ce que nous pouvons pour suivre et
mettre en oeuvre pleinement et
fidèlement les accords conclus entre nos
deux présidents et ramener les relations
sino américaines sur la voie d'une
croissance saine et régulière
une passe d'armes en terrain miné
anthony blinken vient de rentrer d'une
tournée au japon et en corée du sud dont
l'objectif était de consolider les
alliances américaine dans la région et à
la veille de cette réunion à anchorage
washington a annoncé des sanctions
contre une vingtaine de responsables
chinois lié à la reprise en main de hong
kong par pékin pas une façon
d'accueillir ses invités
selon wang les discussions doivent se
poursuivre ce vendredi en alaska où les
deux puissances risque de continuer à
s'écharper